really big news yesterday Senator Dianne
Feinstein who's a Democrat from
California she decided to sort of
unilaterally in a rogue kind of way
released the testimony that took place
before the Senate Judiciary Committee
from a few of the people involved with
fusion GPS what what is fusion GPS why
is this big fusion GPS is the
organization that was involved in the
procurement of that now infamous Trump
Russia dossier and before I get into the
details it's really important to
understand the backstory of this what
fusion gps does more generally is that
they're a research and strategic
intelligence company based in washington
DC they do investigations they do
opposition research related activities
other types of information gathering
Glenn Simpson is the co-founder of
fusion GPS Joshua Levy is a lawyer for
fusion GPS and they and possibly even a
couple of others but they as the primary
most important witnesses for today's
story were called in to testify before
the Senate Judiciary Committee some time
ago about how the Russian Trump dossier
came to be and since more and more
people have been saying well why don't
you release that testimony and part of
the reason why there have been calls to
release the testimony of Simpson and
Levy are because Republicans have been
on a smear campaign against fusion GPS
when the truth is that you can like the
concept of opposition research or you
can dislike it but to question the
legality of it or the ethics of it only
because it turned up this dossier that
said really bad things about the guy
that Trump is like Donald Trump that is
very biased arbitrary and capricious so
what fusion GPS did is they hired
Christopher Steele you probably know
that name by now Christopher Steele is
the private a British corporate
intelligence investigator former mi6
agent he did the actual research for the
dossier and Senators up until now have
refused to release the testimony worse
and Levy talked about how why and when
did you get Christopher Steele to start
working on this dossier what was it that
happened as the dossier was being
developed and a number of these other
relevant questions senator Feinstein has
decided to release the testimony and it
is stunning so let's start with why
dianne feinstein chose to release this
testimony she said in a statement
yesterday the innuendo and
misinformation circulating about the
transcript are part of a deeply
troubling effort to undermine the
investigation into potential collusion
and obstruction of justice the only way
to set the record straight is to make
the transcript public and she did that
and the testimony has now been examined
I looked at dozens of pages yesterday
although not all of them because it is I
think over 300 total pages and I'll give
you some of the highlights because
there's really a lot here number one
Glenn Simpson co-founder of fusion GPS
testified that Christopher Steele told
him that the FBI had a source inside the
Trump Organization during the campaign
now Trump organization it wasn't clear
whether he meant the Trump campaign or
the Donald Trump corporation but the
allegation was that the FBI was talking
some hood to someone close to Donald
Trump during the campaign that's
incredibly notable because why even at
that early phase with someone involved
with Trump be talking to the FBI
Glenn Simpson also testified that the
Trump Organization drastically
understates the value of their buildings
their real estate in order to pay less
in taxes but exaggerated s' the value of
that same real estate in legal filings
to make it appear as though they are a
smaller lending risk when it comes to
securing loan than using their real
estate as collateral not in and of
itself mind-blowing but it does
corroborate this idea that increasingly
the financial related stuff is is
probably of interest to robert muller
and his team glenn simpson testified
that while Trump claims he doesn't know
that Russian mobster oligarch Felix
aider the truth is that Trump does know
the guy and that even after finding out
Trump did that seder was
associated with the Russian mob
continued to associate with Felix aider
fusion GPS attorney Joshua levy claimed
that someone died as a result of the
Trump Russia dossier quote somebody's
already been killed as a result of the
publication of this dossier and no harm
should come to anybody related to this
honest work that is interesting and we
don't know more about that but that is
that is a huge piece of breaking news
that we learned from the release of this
testimony a Glenn Simpson testified that
the FBI believed Chris's information
might be credible because they had other
intelligence that indicated the same
thing and one of those pieces of
intelligence was a human source from
inside the Trump Organization that is
interesting because what it suggests to
us is that the Republican line that this
fake dossier was the sole and lonely
catalyst of Robert Muller's
investigation is not true if you believe
that the Trump Russia dossier is filled
with lies which we know it's not right
increasingly more and more elements of
the Trump Russia dossier are operated
but if you believe that the dossier is
merely lies then you could criticize the
Moller investigation by saying well the
only reason the FBI even started to look
into Trump's campaign is because of this
bogus dossier what we now know is that
whether or not you think the dossier is
bogus and of course again we know that
it is not in total a bogus document
doesn't matter because the FBI was
already looking into Trump's campaign
before the creation of this dossier that
is absolutely major but again if you
watch Fox News or listen to Hannity or
Rush Limbaugh you're not going to get
that picture because this isn't what
they're telling their viewers Dianne
Feinstein is being slammed by some
Republicans for releasing the testimony
although not everybody is upset with her
chuck Grassley is the Republican who
chairs the Judiciary Committee in the
Senate he said it's confounding that
Feinstein would do this in the middle of
an ongoing investigation the problem is
that the investigation Grassley is
talking about
is one he called for by saying we need a
criminal referral for Christopher Steele
in other words chuck Grassley is using
the fact that he created an actual
political witch-hunt of Christopher
Steele as a reason why we shouldn't know
what was said during the testimony of
these two Associates of fusion GPS it's
completely circular reasoning it's what
Peter Boghossian calls a closed loop of
reasoning that you can't get out of
Republican John Cornyn on the other hand
says it's a good thing and that he's
glad that this was actually released and
what I came away with is that the folks
at fusion GPS know what they're doing
that's one of the biggest takeaways I
had from looking through several dozen
pages and a couple of summaries of the
testimony one example is this brief
statement I'm gonna put up on the screen
for you from the testimony where Glenn
Simpson explains the differences between
the Russian and Italian mob operations
he said quote you know Russian organized
crime is very different from Italian
organized crime it's much more sort of a
hybrid kind of thing where they're
involved in politics and banking and
there's even a lot of connections
between the Mafia and the KGB or the FSB
and cybercrime things that the Italians
sort of never figured out stock fraud in
particular was the big thing in the
United States in any event all of that
entered into my thinking when I saw that
Donald Trump was in business with Felix
aider in the Trump Soho project and a
number of other controversial condo
projects this to me is a very savvy and
knowledgeable firm and to go back to
what I said at the beginning you can
find opposition research to be a
despicable game and many of us do and I
in many ways as well but to allege that
fusion GPS by taking on this project by
hiring Christopher Steele was doing
anything particularly or uniquely
illegal immoral or unethical is
absolutely not true these are real
professionals who know what they are
doing so the broad strokes take away
from me is number one professionals
doing high-level research hired a
credible and experienced researcher in
Christopher steel and it's not really
that surprising that over time more and
more elements of the Trump Russia
have been confirmed number two if you
read through the questions and answers
from Republicans and Simpson and levy
and Democrats and Simpson Simpson and
levy you will notice that almost every
question asked by Republicans was a
question focused on trying to demean and
defame the witnesses not figure out the
truth of the Trump Russia dossier even
before they got into this hearing
Republicans came prepared with questions
not meant to figure out oh well how did
Christopher Steele's methods relate to
what the FBI was doing and what elements
of this are sourced in one way or the
other no all their questions were
basically trying to make a Glenn Simpson
and Joshua Levy look bad to discredit
their entire operation and that is a red
flag that we should all be aware of and
lastly even before fusion GPS hired
Christopher Steele what we learn from
the testimony was that fusion GPS was
already aware of Donald Trump's
connections to crime bosses in Russia
they were already aware of Donald
Trump's connection to others mob tied
people in the former Soviet states steel
was hired not to generate new
information but to fill in gaps in a
framework that fusion GPS already had so
only further telling us that the dossier
itself was not presenting completely new
and previously unseen information
diffusion GPS and furthermore that the
dossier as we've heard from James
clapper and others was not the catalyst
or the FBI and for fusion GPS to start
looking into the connections between
Donald Trump and Russia be they
connections related to the campaign
financial connections and other
connections to Russians like Felix aider
the mob connected Russian oligarch this
is major in terms of how it refocuses
what we now know to be the robert muller
investigation you're not going to hear
this analysis on right-wing media in
many ways you're not going to hear it on
corporate media but those are the
revelations that I gleaned from this
send me your thoughts about what you got
from the release of
this testimony if you've checked it out
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the show
is on twitter at david pakman show the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership